we are live guys what's going on Jason
Carter here at RuPaul's Drag con la 2019
with someone who needs no introduction
but I'm gonna give you one
he is the mother of drag one of the most
influential people in the LGBT community
RuPaul author of the queen of drama
queen of drag witching / amina stuff
look how beautiful this is
this we haven't shown you the product
room is the Mallee anti-shine that I
love and it's over there in both 1543 is
that what she said yes so fabulous it
just worked so beautifully like that and
where can they find this this is the
RuPaul Mally this is the the mattifier
yes yes you can go to QVC it's also at
Ulta and it's also at Kohl's not cold
god oh god right yes I love it whoo good
to see you good to see you too and
you've got your clothes on I have my
clothes on goodness I know shocker
shocker track on the fifth annual and
get this the fifth this is the fifth
annual yeah five years five years of
rhyme goodness look at all oh my god
it's brilliant bigger than ever bigger
than ever and so many beautiful people
you know I get to look around and see
all of the people walking through the
alleyways of drag Con and where they out
Los Angeles Convention Center everyone
is dressed in wild outfits totally
little kids dressed in wild a family
event is a family event and it makes me
so happy that our show has given birth
to this expression free expression
because that's what life's all about
I think through Drakon as I said many
times is this global phenomenon the
Emmys history-making Emmys I think when
you started doing this show ten years
ago that it would be the cultural gem
that it is no we just wanted to have fun
we knew that we wanted to create a
platform for to really celebrate drag
the art of drag and expression and that
was really the goal because I love drag
even although you know I do drag I am a
fan
drag and I wanted to celebrate it and
that's what happened and here we are
we're about to start our 12th season or
12th year of doing drag race with how
popular RuPaul's Drag Race is Joost you
think drag is now mainstream I think
that on the surface it's mainstream but
on a deeper level it can never be
mainstream because drag challenges
people to look beyond what their
driver's license
describes them as sure drag challenges
you to discover your true self and your
true self is an extension of the power
that created the whole universe and that
is that's a big that's a lot for most
people to to take in so in that respect
most people won't be able to still can't
be mainstream you know what I mean yeah
it's going all deep yeah it does it goes
deep and that's why it will never
replace drag is is dangerous it's not
politically correct and it is it's sassy
it's sassy for sure root but with that
though and how popular drag race is and
how you just said you are the queen of
drag you have legions of fans across the
world that look up to you that that are
inspired by you do you feel pressure
before you have a real super
responsibility
I don't feel pressure I should I don't
feel pressure because I know that it
starts with me if I have a good time
they can have a good time and so it's
really and I think that's true if even
if you're not in show business
everything starts with you whether you
have children on the plane they say put
the max on your child on yo face before
you put it on your child face that's
true in life too if you are having a
good time if you are living your best
life and taking care of yourself then
you can take care of other people so I
don't feel pressure I I feel honored I
feel very fortunate yeah do you pinch
yourself sometimes I think wow this is
all real I do when I'm looking out
you know I have a room overlooking the
whole event I do sort of think wow this
is really amazing but it's not just from
me it's from all of the courageous souls
out there who have the courage to live
their live their life you know we've
said this many times on our show that
drag race is really about the tenacity
of the human spirit and I think that's
why I connect with audiences around the
world you know
everybody's you know not going to go out
and with a florescent green wig but
everyone has a dream that they think
well maybe the world won't accept it
here we have a room full of people who
have said you know what I'm gonna do my
own thing and that's courageous
and that's powerful there's powerful and
it's it takes it do take nerve it do
take nerve I mean look at me the fans
are here they love you let's talk about
what you're up to these days you have
been a mainstay in pop culture for close
to 40 years now I think it's about 80
years I got my start after World War one
yeah but no seriously you know acting we
loved you on Grayson Frankie now now AJ
and the Queen tell us about that we're
super excited AJ and the queen is a show
on Netflix that comes out in January
that was created by match Michael
Patrick King and myself and it's a story
of a down-on-her-luck drag queen who had
picks up a stowaway in her RV of this
ten year old girl and it's it's the most
challenging thing I've ever done why
entirely because it's it's acting like a
real him and usually in acting roles I
played the gay best friend or the
neighbor this is a fully rounded human
being with all the emotions and you know
we shot that for five months did we're
in the writers room for you know two
months and then
you know I had to memorize pages and
pages of dialogue some some days I had
11 pages of dialogue to memorize and
then the next day it would be 8 pages in
the next day so it was it was a
challenge but I'm so proud of it and
Michael Patrick King is a genius Sex in
the City he we love him the two Broke
Girls and to come back and he is
fantastic and so smart and so nurturing
and he was my guide he was the one who
really ushered and and nursed my
performance and I'm very very proud of
it comes out in January we cannot wait
yeah acting and now you are making your
for way back into daytime television
true the RuPaul show guys give it up we
cannot wait for the rootball so yes
summer tell us it comes wrong on a June
10th on Fox stations
it's called RuPaul it's a daytime talk
show and it's so much fun it's just like
you know when we're hanging out a drag
race and we're backstage just talking
it's very relaxed it's a play it's a
destination place where friends can get
together and talk we got guests Paula
Abdul and Sierra and Iggy Azalea tons of
gas just to name a few
yeah no we it's we're having a great
time was it daunting coming back into
this arena that is roulette let's keep
it real it's highly competitive and a
lot of shows don't make it pass a test
run were you were you a little hesitant
with any trepidation well you know this
is the thing you've been in show I've
been in show this for a long long time
you do a lot of projects most projects
do not work which is fine some do some
don't you just go in and you do your
best and see what happens but you know
if it works great if it doesn't that's
okay okay you know but I'm having a
great time and you know I used to
practice being a talk show host when I
was a kid watching Johnny Carson and
Murph Griffith and you know Dinah Shore
Mike Douglas so I love talking Plus you
know we've been doing a podcast
she'll visage and I for I don't have for
years something like that but very very
what's the T our podcast and Michelle
and I used to do morning Drive radio in
New York 20 23 years ago so it feels
very natural and hopefully it'll connect
with the audience well from from early
showings it seems like it is a fans are
really attaching to your your your
sentiment of everybody say love and yeah
how welcoming there's such a light fair
room well thank you thank you it's so
needed today you know there's so much
divisive nough sin the world right now
and you know I want to be part of the
the the mending of that I want to be
part of that discussion yeah and the
talk show is part of that drag race is a
part of that you know I I believe in
love I believe in kindness yeah so
you're so successful I legendary world
renown what's next for you if you seem
like you you've conquered everything
like where does RuPaul go next well I
love colors I love music I love dancing
I love things that I love kindness I'm
going to keep following that I would
love to do a line of clothing or you
know I'd love to go on tour one day you
know but so far I haven't had I haven't
had time to do it because we're doing
these TV shows but I'd love to go on
tour
that'd be nice will they ever come a
time where you'll say you know what I'm
good
no no I love being creative whether I'm
making money or not I love being
creative so as long as there's a piece
of paper and a I don't know it's up some
tape I can be creative to create
something that's that's what I'm about
so I'm gonna keep doing that I'll keep
doing that okay guys give it up for
RuPaul we are so so honored to have you
thank you for all you do I'm so blessed
to be a part of drag race I know the
fans and everyone crying we're all know
proud of you I know have you're part of
the et family and I think you are the
bee's knees Jason you are fabulous
thank you guys all right RuPaul Charles
from RuPaul's Drag Race and RuPaul's
rack on La always a good time you guys
stick with the stream this is et live
alive at RuPaul drop all track on